hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay we just got
past the wobbly stairs of go no
awareness so we're gonna leap across
this chasm here oh oh oh oh what okay
damn it
alright well that guy I need to get my
failures all out of the way right off
the bat okay let's try this again
there we go hello okay these are all the
same
since they're gonna come after me with
knives
Oh Oh
all what to hell
[Music]
laughs former up in here
there we go got it
Wow holy crap oh man what is going on
here
noise not fun fun times
where did I go
[Music]
Wow
gonna be kidding me where am I going
down there it's gotta be it huh oh oh I
made it
Oh what the hell I slid off that's
confusing okay
[Music]
leave an epic oh come on you run out of
jumpin juice come on be beaten by a
puzzle or not even a puzzle design
platform
okay now I gotta wait patiently flame
running me to decrease
oh there we go and then wait a bit oh
shut up guy there we go now
they look around here it's hard to even
tell where
I kinda almost made it I'd let
accidentally let go the controls over
it's like go down
try to go and then get out here and you
okay you gotta jump from here to there
huh there we go
got it got it nailed it ah so great
oh man I'm wondering if the designer
like wanted to put gravity on here so
that you could like gravitate towards
where you wanted to go for stick to the
ground at least it didn't work out that
way
fear there
okay oh it's got it got it got it
oh come on mother of [ __ ] I was not good
at that platform
[Music]
whatever whatever I'll get past I know
how to get there now
whatever wait a bit all right
[Music]
now I know why these all these guys are
crying gnashing their teeth there we go
oh come on you push me up no not exit
[Music]
baloney baloney I was right there at the
end oh right there right there I was
makes me grumpy you know I see me when
I'm grumpy if a love you want to see me
when I'm grumpy you'll see a number of
requiem' part 5
ah yeah you're all laughing at me aren't
you my failures oh this is how I do all
platformers I make it to the end on like
the second or first drive and then I'll
never be able to get the same way ever
again this debit
so smack gravity you
Oh God is that that was the wrong way
wasn't it she just jumped down here to
tonight oh of course of course
Oh Oh
why didn't you tell me guys betrayal
trusted you
all right there we go
go easy now
don't eff this up bro bro
there we go bro okay call oh I took ten
billion times longer than it should have
long empty hallway oh hello my life that
fateful night the child lay upon the
road broken why did you have to walk
that way so late young man why did you
have to be so foolish disillusioned and
embittered by his parents words the
child was broken physically broken
mentally the men and white placed him in
the rolling chairs how he laughed how he
laughed and so he lived what remained of
his life one day fate smiled upon the
child and so we came upon the implement
of his destruction decisions decisions
the outcome was not certain pro-capital
icterus
haven't soooo father Lebel ii my life
okay we see here we got a car wheel
chair gun the car relates to the car
that hit the guy wheelchair wheelchair
that put him in the hospital or book
book gun is for fighting
learning c-bro cactus lick lick tourists
hobbits who have father Lebel II I'm not
pronouncing that right updating them
okay so obviously I have to choose one
of these doors I don't know try the gun
okay the gun put me out there through
the car gun through the car wheelchair
oh I see it just loops all right well I
got some puzzle wait a minute oh yeah I
let's see here captive doors have
include sue a fondant belly decisions
decisions
okay maybe I go through in a certain
order the story of his life maybe go
through the car one first and through
the car with wheelchair
[Music]
then book then fight let me just try it
what seems logical car wheelchair at
least wheelchair these two fighting
these two book ah got it
holy crap I got it okay I thought that
was gonna take way longer for me to get
oh boy I'm going wrong here
hello oh boy
good
I need to head to the exit okay I'm
right here
okay I don't like this
Oh
oh god oh my god oh my goodness okay
okay oh no oh oh straight and then okay
I'm Oh sir
I'm going right way
okay this way and then left the trail
got dark it's okay but if a guy
accidentally done aa guy guy guy guy are
you going off you want them you want
some face man oh oh oh gonna be like in
this circle or something come here hey
you wanta in a circle circle circle just
go around sir okay I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got it I got the guys
I got it
what yes he suffered severe spinal
damage in the accident
uh-huh it's a miracle he still retains
upper body much from the waist down
however there is no nervous response at
all not to mention the mental trauma he
suffered
aha from what I can tell Simon is a
deeply disturbed individual who had
mental problems too even prior to the
accident right well thanks whoa huh get
away get away get away man
getting mental problems
holy [ __ ]
oh well pick one man
close
look it up
is he still there
yeah course he is what the [ __ ] what's
not this where I came from sounded you
are one deeply this no no no something
is obviously not right obviously we
should hurry man before something else
happens yeah
[Music]
chapter 5 leaving this room my way I got
one bullet left for you
oh no one believed in this I have no
idea what the hell no oh wait they're
all up the headshot boom hotel you gotta
be kidding me anyone else you wall want
some get some specs on bed man that shot
Jimmy give me your guns headshot
just gimme gimme going give me on my bed
guys
that would that other guy died when you
drop his gun there is there is my bad
guy yeah yeah you go have fun
whatever the hell
I need to find a safe
wait what I just going back this way
maybe I don't know maybe it'll change
now because he's kind of wanted let me
through
[Music]
however it might fall all right
Claire
won't let me through again so I was like
don't go that way keeping the
sledgehammer got a single dose of
morphine
yeah I'll use the morphine for now just
to fill me up and then they'll give me
more probably
take out the fuse
it's a point
this episode's there's gonna be a bit
longer I'm sure you're almost waiting oh
dude episodes lo long okay what is this
crap okay boo yeah and I'm hoping it's
gonna point me in the right direction
sometime soon maybe I'm trying to like
go through the city to find the place of
the accident in in Simon's mind okay
where am I
this way say boy nope no see why would
they give me a save save point oh
there's a save point in the bus okay
this is where the bus is let's go to the
booth booth okay say point Punk you will
not survive I survived
I will spy long as I know how to live
all right all right thank you guys so
much for watching
that's all the time I got for this up so
yeah as always I'll see you in the next
part
bye bye